please welcome john airingmen
hello
i'm super excited to be here and share
some tips with you guys some actionable
tips and all that um i mean it's been
such a journey i really enjoy this stuff
it's my passion so all right so the
topic of money can be very intimidating
what sparked your interest
yeah so growing up uh you know i was we
never really talked about money in our
household and that's like millions of
other people we don't talk about money
because it's a taboo subject and so that
was kind of the narrative that i grew up
with is like we don't talk about money
with other people you know and so that's
kind of what sparked my interest in that
curiosity of money
and that's why i start to encourage
people to talk about money because
if we don't have these uncomfortable
conversations
then we're never gonna learn about money
and if we never learn about money then
we're not gonna you know make informed
financial decisions about our money and
if we don't make informed financial
decisions you know we're going to end up
in debt like the video shows so it's
it's you need to talk and have that
conversation with friends and family
members so how did you become a
full-time financial influencer yeah well
i went to the university of cincinnati i
graduated with a finance degree in 2018
and i became a financial accountant and
because i was having these uncomfortable
conversations with people these money
conversations people started coming to
me more and more have asking the same
questions over and over and so i was
like instead of answering the same
question why not i just make some videos
about it and at the time in 2019 tick
tock was starting to gain some traction
right and it just slowly kept taking off
and so now i'm uh i quit my job i'm a
full-time finfluencer now is what they
call it financial influencer so
um yeah and it's just given me so many
opportunities to talk to people and to
come on your show drew so it's just been
amazing
[Music]